people most affected by coronavirus in
United States are black people okay hold
on a second who's most affected by the
green New Deal who's most affected by
the coda protocol which would skyrocket
energy costs which for us is mildly
inconvenient because you drive a
crossover but for someone in Zambia or
honestly you ought to go that far for
someone in Mexico if you can wander out
of your cancun booze cruise resorts they
work all week just to get enough fuel so
they can heat a can of beans on an old
ironing board in a drum who do you think
is most affected by your green policy
it's inconvenient for us it kills people
in the third world who make $2 a month
it's a CNN Town Hall and this is
actually it's going to former acting CBC
director Richard Besser okay former HHS
Secretary Kathleen Sebelius and activist
Greta soon bird what they join Anderson
Cooper and dr. Sanjay Gupta for a live
CNN Town Hall about the corona vibe like
the other yeah what happened to the
experts we have the head of the CDC we
have a neurosurgeon and we have an
autistic girl who yells how dare you I
think she's perfect for the panel yes
more important right now according to
the media than shaming everyone for
everything that they do really good
raises the intelligence I'm not saying I
agree I'm just saying you got to respect
her shameless I respect her shame game
yeah so um I do think a couple of facts
the kind of hitting and we'll discuss
this a little bit of course the left
have tried to set this up already
they're attacking anyone who questions
the co vid stats they're not even
makovan statistics but the initial
coronavirus statistics that have been
proven verifiable the four to seven
percent death rates the two million dead
by the way super shout-out to our
wonderful researcher reg the bandits /
reg the news for calling Neil Ferguson
that guy's name
we got him so they've been trying to
frame of course everyone who says you
know what I think we need to reopen the
economy I think we need to balance lives
and livelihoods as science deniers right
and so they're trying to now equate the
denial of Co vid being you know a virus
with a 10% death rate or like Ebola with
a fifty-year sent death rate we're all
it's all the same people equal deny
science just like climate change okay
we'll come back to the second aoc she
even did a video
where she was talking about kovat being
a test run for how to approach climate
change and she's been saying the green
New Deal is scientifically necessary
again let's go to the experts started
with politicians who ignored warnings by
scientists it continued through a
program of us knowing that we needed to
act quickly and needed to take dramatic
action fast in order to contain the
damage but there's so much that's
politically vested in making sure that
we don't do that right
for example this idea it's like many
scientists and epidemiologist started
saying listen we have to shut down our
cities in our state's immediately right
now just as a as an immediate precaution
because we did not take action earlier
the communities that suffer first are
the ones that are working class black
brown essential workers are not white
people all of that parallels with the
climate movement it is scientifically
informed this is scientifically informed
legislation I'm not here to tell you
what is politically easy I'm here to
tell you what is scientifically
necessary doctor I like I like her use
of the very lawyerly word inform
scientifically informed not
scientifically based not scientifically
sourced yeah and typically in vote I
just were near this when he was created
around she would be served well to
attend finishing school from LeBron
James yes anyway I'm going my duty to
inform as I conversate mmm-hmm you are
just lovely here's the thing too I just
find it so funny that all of a sudden
they call their own experts yeah yeah
well why would you listen to doctor
bricks we need to listen to experts like
a ococ show another fact the World
Economic Forum let's let's you think I I
make this up I'm trying to inextricably
titus they're now calling for a
flattening of the climate curve Oh
what so many curves
it's like Raquel Welch it so curvy we
heard this before yeah it's the word
first time I'm surprised they're using
them now because it's no longer about
flattening the couvade curve yeah it's
about the cure the curve is irrelevant
we've already flattened the curve who
gives a rat's ass according to Elsie we
shouldn't come back until every man
woman and child has a vaccine and
microchip from Bill Gates another fact
the UN chief uses Earth Day speech to
confront Trump on climate change he was
linking it of course to coronavirus and
saying that it was the bigger threat
and then finally UC Berkeley they've
hosted a panel I think this year what's
the panel the panel is environmental and
energy experts those people like to
discuss the current covin 19 pandemic
offer lessons and how shared global
solutions can help beat back the
continued threat of climate change so a
couple of things here by the way hit the
notification Val if you're subscribed
hit all notifications because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot and
just check in every single day here
because we of course crowd orbits um
this is remarkable to me and I wanna
hear what you guys have to say about
this because we've heard from the
experts who's denying science at this
point who is denying science when we I
mean let's just let's just use the most
extreme examples okay the most extreme
examples humanly possible the people who
said this is about comparable to the flu
and they were just scoria like I can't
believe labor they were taken behind the
woodshed
how could you downplay this versus the
initial expert who had to resign in
shame saying two million dead so let's
say it's double the number of right now
yeah right let's say we're at a hundred
and fifty thousand deaths flu season
we've had flu seasons with eighty
thousand deaths versus two million it is
so much closer to the crazy non experts
who said it's more comparable to the flu
that it wouldn't even appear on the same
line chart now we have a new model and
so I wonder when they say we're going to
get rid of misinformation on social
media you know Twitter Facebook YouTube
well for a second I mean does that
include the World Health Organization
saying that it couldn't be transmitted
from human human contact oh well no no
we won't remove that because that's what
we believed at the time of the
information we had Taiwan saying have a
minute so so many meaty requests yeah
and why did you believe it because of
the tweets right
because of the tweets what about the
tweets out there from the Chinese
ambassador who said that it was started
by American troops well that was based
on the information we had at that time
come against it hold on you're gonna
have a problem with pizza gate but not
the Chinese ambassador saying it was
marine you saw avatar it is remarkable
to me how inconsistent it is here here's
what we said early on I think okay
understand a precautionary measure when
we didn't have any data exactly we
didn't have any information okay you
shut down for a little bit or you take
some precautionary measures where you
quarantine the sick and the vulnerable
because that's typically what you do you
quarantine the sick not the hiding
that's understandable especially when we
were hearing from China by the way in
the World Health Organization that it
could be a seven print well of course we
want to do that but now in the face of
overwhelming data we're even left as
governors tell us okay it's about a 0.5%
death rate now at the top end in the
face of data you are still pushing to
ruin people's lives why well you know
what why listen to allow us to make our
case as we present the experts Greta
your witness well and that they're using
the same term that evidently worked to
make people shut down the entire economy
it makes you realize oh that's the goal
yes okay well let's use the same terms
that at least are gonna have the same
results right and that's of the growing
front yeah and in the article that even
went back just going back on that point
said that if the the basic thing was
saying that people were a climate denier
there's same people that are saying the
Kovan thing wasn't that the models
weren't wrong it's just that we had
stuff happen like you social distancing
happened right close it down we're like
wait a minute no you factored that in to
begin with right and you said that even
with that this was going to be the case
right so tell me in the climate thing
what you're going to do yeah
then you're gonna change the model and
then you're gonna move the goalposts
together then you're gonna exclude China
from the equation and then we're still
all gonna say been wrong it ever nearly
every single things I don't want to be
Donald Trump that like they've been
wrung at every single turn all everyone
Nestea they were wrong about Georgia
yeah they're wrong about Georgia and so
they have to move the goalposts now - no
- no longer the goal posts are no longer
a hostage everyone's gonna die if you
open up your economy cuz in Texas guess
what nowhere near as severe as Michigan
nowhere near
the kind of infection we have a lot of
big cities here in Texas it's not just
some small state with podunk towns we
were reasonable in our approach and I'm
not saying that not happening in
lockdowns is more effective than having
lock downs I'm saying there is no rhyme
or reason to the at this point when you
look at the statistics outside of the
fact that it's dangerous if you're over
80 or have pre-existing comorbidities
that's what we know the rest we don't
they said everyone's gonna die
needlessly in Georgia well Georgia is
now beyond the curve right well they're
doing just fine like they're seeing kind
of this cliff fall-off that we talked
about that we're just fine because of
course every life matters worsen but the
risk that we are used to taking every
single day of our lives that maybe we
just didn't know that we were taking
every year we have a flu risk every year
we have a death by automobile accident
risk or by murder or by something
happening in the hospital when you go in
for a procedure that's not supposed to
kill you that accidentally does and all
my sires showing up in a sequel well
that's true a really good point I mean I
know well but the comparison to reality
of how many lives are actually lost and
the changes it's not just about how many
more lives have been lost due to kovat
but compared to what our normal death
rates would have been compared to the
risk like you're saying yeah and when
you actually do then you're not just
screaming about politics and and people
saying if you open the economy you hate
every human being right it just it all
falls apart just like we've learned this
one we're talking about the economy
we've had some lessons that we've
learned from us right here the federal
government can't be a charity well you
know the federal government can help
right now a couple things that shows you
how politicize it is because right now
Democrats and all the Republicans are
holding up this new stimulus bill hold
on a second who held up the stimulus
bill before we flattened the curve
remember you guys wanted to shove it
everything in there with earmark unity
Center funding it was that we need to do
this so that we can flatten the curve
now that we've flattened the curve and
you're talking about another stimulus
which a lot of it can be a big giant
kickback to the postal union when you
actually look at what they want to do at
this point we'll pass the curve now
you're trying to play politics with it
and say Republicans are trying to stop
the spending bill you guys we're doing
it when we actually needed it but let's
assume for a second when people say well
there's there's no choice between making
a living right in the economy or staying
healthy if the government just does its
job how much money have we spent now
true numbers truly many trillions about
more than at more nor than ever as far
as acute spending in history the United
States that floated us for a month yeah
if that so how much if you spend more
right you spy let's you know let's call
it twenty trillion dollars I'll entire
debt clock three 53.59 enough money and
by the way it runs out faster if nobody
is worried so we've learned that the
federal government cannot be a charity
it's not Samaritan's Purse but you know
what else that businesses at this it's a
self-sustaining charity you go to your
local coffee shop you go to your
restaurant that allows them to provide a
living not only for the business owners
but their employees when you are
voluntarily offering money for goods or
services and something else I think is
undeniable here what we're talking about
the climate change dream movement they
want to equate the two and you know what
so do I just like they wanted you to
remember coronavirus and Donald Trump's
handling of it going into November yeah
I want you to remember all of it two
million dead 7% deaths right please do
not forget we've been consistent I want
you to remember when they accuse us of
being science deniers because of our
position on coronavirus here's something
interesting to me this has proven beyond
any shadow of a doubt that absolutely
positively struming Trump no exceptions
no exceptions how many I should none you
can hear me stutter do I do I look like
a Koster that the green movement hates
people think about this for I was at I
was at a co-op health food store in
Michigan by the way huge culture of fear
in Michigan compared to Texas yeah I was
walking in to get some get some yogurt I
have a mask because you have to
otherwise it's very illegal this lady
who's my age has a mask and I'm walking
pastoring at yogurt and she looks she
stops panics and leaps into the next
island oh my god and then when I go to
checkout they have a big sign like it is
with it is with extreme extreme sadness
that we have to inform you do to the
coronavirus we are not accepting
reusable bags at this time
that we are not accepting reusable cups
at this time I'm going all the way to
second a flush list urinal how'd you
figure that out by the way there's no
secret to it your piss just stays there
yeah it's just pools there can you even
the sports bars put in ice or peanut
shells or some fleshless you're like
well that's kind of gross
and then like well I'm gonna go wash my
hands and sing happy birthday twice and
happy birthday to happy and the sink
shuts off cause it's a green sink and I
can't use paper towels cuz it's a blow
dryer every when it comes down to saving
human lives with all of us we have to
get rid of the absurdity of the the
plastic that the reusable bags by the
way are worse for the environment and
the reusable cup from not gonna do that
anymore
what about following the CDC
hand-washing guidelines I can't do it
it's not humanly possible what about the
flush list urinals hey no more flushing
no more running water that's progress
I'm going to piss my name into a tree is
that progress that's skills this is what
the left would see when they see the
evolution and going up going up and then
down to a squatty potty and then
eventually it's made of hemp in there
and we're in San Francisco so when we're
talking about this yeah listen my
position and I think everyone here on
Climate change's no no listen I think
the earth has warmed I think that humans
may be contributing a significant amount
to it as to whether it will have
catastrophic results I'm not entirely
sure as to the proposed global
legislation that would kill people
undeniably expecting of course China to
play ball which they've read vocally
expressed they will not no I don't
believe that politically it will make
any difference and as it relates to
coronavirus I believe it relied to or at
the very least provided misinformation
certainly from China certainly from
experts if we can have 2 million people
dead I've literally shut down the
economy based on statistics that
couldn't exactly be observed you know
what is observable you know it's 100
cent observable joblessness oh people
not making any money
yeah right suicides going left all ISM
going up there's no doubt about that so
when you folks want to say hey we deny
the experts by the way Burke's not an
expert
only Sochi only Japan
I will wear it proudly it's so funny to
me as they talk about you know this
global economy right there we are all
one we are the world hold hands and have
all the flags effectively an Amish quilt
but really when you think about it okay
you look at the globe and you look at
the green movement and then they have
the gall to tell us well really the
people most affected by environmental
pollutants are minorities in the United
States the people most affected by
coronavirus in United States are black
people okay hold on a second who's most
affected by the green New Deal who's
most affected by the co2 protocol which
would skyrocket energy costs which for
us is mildly inconvenient because you
drive a cross over but for someone in
Zambia or honestly you ought to go that
far for someone in Mexico if you can
wander out of your cancun booze cruise
resorts they work all week just to get
enough fuel so they can heat a can of
beans on an old ironing board in a drum
who do you think is most affected by
your green policy it's inconvenient for
us it kills people in the third world
who make $2 a month so they don't really
care about the most vulnerable among us
certainly I don't want to say no one
cares I'm saying the policies are not
thoughtful of the most vulnerable among
us because it is all a sacrifice at the
altar of the greater good what's the
greater good well the climate the earth
it's more important than people what's
the greater good with coronavirus well
political expediency it's more important
than people being autonomous and being
able to make their own livings so I
won't I'm not gonna make any sacrifices
that adulterer and as it relates to
being anti science being I'm a climate
denier as well as a coronavirus denier I
think you can look at the track record
of where we lined up on climate change
where we've lined up on coronavirus and
it's remarkable remarkable that we've
gotten very little wrong honestly I was
speaking I got thinking this is gonna
come back to bite many ass instead I
look like Nostradamus so I will wear
that loudly and proudly yep
call me a science denier you know what's
in here it's just water that's why they
call it acting but it actually smells
garlicky there's something wrong with
the water I think it's going through the
icemaker we don't have we don't have the
baking soda in the fridge if you liked
this video subscribe hit notifications
or just check back every single day
because we upload a new video every
single day this was actually taken from
the full show a full hour show the way
upload every single Thursday click that
right now go watch the entire show if
you don't want to you don't you don't
have to but if you if you stop by you
know just don't bother me I'm gonna
enjoy my garlic water